[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey everybody happy Tuesday I'm John
Luke I'm joined by Jake hello and we're
playing Assassin's Creed curse of the
Pharaohs it's the second DLC for
Assassin's Creed origins let's just pop
right into that we are playing on ps4 so
bear with us this loading screen is long
really long oh my god
yeah ps4 not not a pro yeah so this is
the second DLC I never played the first
one I've seen a little bit of this one
at a preview event and it actually has
some kind of cool stuff in it like you
you go to like that Egyptian afterlife
location yeah it's got like giant
scorpions and all this like stuff so
we're gonna try and get to that well
this is like the beginning of the DLC so
you're gonna kind of see it it's also
got some interesting mechanics you'll
see at the beginning we're like there
there's like sort of these like undead
Pharaohs like Cleopatra I think no not
Cleopatra she's alive in this game yeah
say she's no what's her name we'll find
out is that because you actually is here
what's up cube four years have passed
since we laid the last to rest but the
Creed Spurs us ever on once I have
captured a messenger very news of
another I see much takes place after the
main game one who hasn't yet got it
really yeah I didn't beat the game
either so I don't know perfect we're the
most qualified I mean I almost played
through it twice because we had that
review event where we had riot go to
Ubisoft and play it and I got I must
have played 50 hours in a span of a week
and I didn't finish actually maybe not
that much but I played a lot didn't
finish and then we finally got code and
once again didn't have time to finish
yeah I played a decent amount but I'll
still need some you know practive
practice alright we'll forgive you then
Loras is Nefertiti that is the one okay
yeah so like kind of like mummy style
like Nefertiti like shows up and is like
like trying to attack you and stuff and
what's cool is actually yummy style is
Brendan Fraser I wish I was trying to
think of like good mummy quotes to bring
up during this but I can't I'm gonna be
honest like I love that movie but I
can't actually really think I'm in
quotes
Chad hit me up with your favorite
Brendan Fraser mummy quotes
oh this is like a nice yeah this is like
the mummy here right
Oh No
do I have to fight this thing yes hey
you're now level 45 so that's the cool
thing that this has where you can if
you're not high enough level for the DLC
when you go to your save you can tell it
like hey I want to play the DLC and
it'll take your save make a copy of it
and then boost that copy to level 45 so
you can just play the DLC without
affecting your original save which is
actually a really cool way of handling
that and more games should do that you
just as ask Mike I'm sure he knows every
line man
well Mike just has a stupid memory
that's true oh boy oh you're dead that
was a one hit kill oh no gotta be
quicker this time it's got to be quicker
the world has been loaded it's just like
Alex wordings back there oh boy
maybe I should mess with some of the
perks now that I'm level 45 first before
I yeah maybe maybe I saw you got like a
bunch of equipment so maybe yeah absent
cuz that thing had ton of health
so once a game side effort origins can
you livestream Assassin's Creed the
three tyranny of King Washington and
also I don't know any Brendan Fraser
mummy quotes and we definitely won't be
streaming that yeah uh man I never even
played that that DLC all right I got
some better stuff but I don't know if
it's good enough
oh yeah no I got 40 45 equipment okay
she's the outfit you've been doing
deuces mike has a crush on Brendan
Fraser he told me in secret
maybe you Brian Frazier hasn't done
anything a good outfit yeah well
equipped that's what he got me with
whatever when I play this I just like
stayed away and use the the bow I was
doing that at first I was hardly doing
any damage though but I had a crap boat
nice little crab boat quit yes yeah
there you go get that good bow oh this
is definitely the kind of game where you
haven't played in a while you're just
like wait what buttons do what how do i
you think it is similar to Dark Souls so
like I remember some of it yeah look the
basic like combat flow Wow third of my
health
you got your dude use your uh or one
hour to ability oh yeah there you go and
then hit again oh no oh boy
keep standing up one more joke bear
shadows return to the end yeah get out
of here I beat it did you see that yeah
you did it man Congrats all right so
this is actually kind of cool the way
the DLC works is as you're doing the
main story you'll get like a
notification that's like oh the Pharaoh
shadow is popped up it's like a nemesis
thing or it'll just kind of like up here
and you have to like fight it or you
could run away but that's actually
pretty neat ability points spend it's
like matt has thoroughly looked through
this though this looks cool get some
headshots XP yeah I don't think these
are gonna help us a lot I'll see mr. Jay
he doubted you thought you were gonna
get gonna get rekt again but no way
we're professionals over here
yeah I'd recommend just kind of cruising
through the main mission stuff so we can
get to that cool okay afterlife area
because I think that's really like the
interesting part of this DLC although I
believe this here Pheebs is like a whole
new area I can look on the map as far as
I'm aware it is again this is me like
this this is all this is all new yeah
that's actually a sizable little area
yeah that's pretty cool yeah this is
definitely new it looks the same now
that's very similar it looks like Egypt
you missed much with the
[Music]
the discovery to birthing um no I have
not it really interested me though yeah
if your Friday looking for the person is
just that quest marker there
kill that guy I hope nice yeah I
remember doing that a lot with the bow
just sort of like strafing into there
yes of aiming just like I'll strafe and
eventually when their heads lined up
I'll do that no feel icky tyranny of the
man with death in his oh I kinda liked
how they would do that - gay even like -
would do that were little occasional you
say just like a word and I can tell you
something and the most ancient relic has
been stolen from gotta find it did the
main game ever get into like weird
supernatural stuff like yeah kind of yes
it did I'd say it did it was it was like
dream stuff okay so does this I guess
what I'm wondering is like does this
whole like hey there's a like Pharaoh
the undead pharaoh like is that feel out
of well I think it works like a stretch
because I'm okay with that one the the
DLC is you know they get into like
weirder stuff like you know there's that
alternate history DLC or like George
Washington
yeah and I was like the Jack the Ripper
one and yeah really good somebody says
bring Greg Kasavin back to spot all
right we just got a bunch of quests I
mean I love Greg Kasavin
as well like he was a huge influence
when I was a kid I used to know kid
whatever like high school no so I used
to like watch his reviews all the time
but my cool games though yeah it's not
like he's sitting there waiting for our
call or anything like that dudes moved
on to other things it's like one day
they'll call me back if you want to see
Greg Kasab and stuff go play a bunch of
supergiant games yeah they're all pretty
dang good
he's like the lead writer on all those
now real good I still haven't played the
most recent hire me where I filtered
insanely good things but yeah I feel
really bad having not played at Bastion
in transistor are some one thing in a
state
yeah you just gotta kill any kind of to
go on talking to people find something
rare golden I have gold you need a drink
fi a lady friend whatever you want you
won't find better indeed it's all we
need
how about you looking for something
special
ancient man this definitely looks I mean
still looks good but it does not look as
good as having seen it unlike the one
accent yeah bro like you can tell the
colors are so much stronger out that
woman's not wearing a shirt sweet
Wow okay alright and dude we got a we
gonna get kicked off of Twitter I don't
think that was out of nowhere but yeah
all the Coach things it seemed more
colorful on the X for some reason as
well as the resolution is much better
it's crisper but right yeah look better
I don't know I mean I bet there's a good
digital foundry video that breaks all
that down yeah this guy's gonna show me
ways that this guys are definitely my
go-to when it comes to that kind of
stuff I feel like I can trust amongst
all the merchants
little down
all right where we going
what do you think they're gonna do after
this for Assassin's Creed it's a good
question it kind of seems like
ubisoft's kind of trying to go the
direction that they did with siege where
it's like continually supporting a game
over a period of time which I don't know
how well that'll work with Assassin's I
don't know if you can do that with
assassin's creed my guess is at least I
hopefully this one oh [ __ ] hi buddy
my guess is no no that's fine focus on
this because if they were to do that I
don't think you could do it I feel like
this game's not built for that yeah they
would have to make a new game that would
maybe be more built for continuous stop
you're right that I think there was like
a recent Ubisoft like like they're gonna
focus more on what it like live services
live service that's the new hot phrase
that all the publishers like to use now
my guess is they won't make them yearly
but I bet I mean of course you're
sending in more Assassin's Creed yeah I
think that'll stop I just don't really
yeah I don't I don't think we're gonna
get one this year for sure I bet you we
won't see one till at least next year I
think this year we'll get the division
oh definitely I think they've said it I
notice they said it's gonna be at e3
they did
lease in the chat says hi I'm new
Madhu's hello welcome Brian hops once
Roman Greece well Rome is already there
yeah yeah the the the work they kind of
have like half the work done having
something specifically in like Greece
and would actually be kind of cool yeah
so I'm around like the Greek gods would
be actually pretty interesting um I've
always wanted Japan I was always kind of
my big one like yeah I'm surprised this
still haven't really done it like Edo
period
Japan samurai like Shogun that kind of
stuff would be really really cool I've
been off the loot fool I've been on a
big jockeys a kick in the office right
now oh yeah but uh so they made a it
never came out here it's called a Ryoga
go to qu yishun which is the name of
Ryoga go to qu is the name of the aqua
so series in Japan and it is basically a
version of that game that takes place
during the end of the Edo period so we
like it's all the same character this is
what they're like playing like samurai
remember history yeah so it was
apparently a launch title for the ps4 it
actually looks like really cool okay and
it's not available here not available
here they never reported it and I really
would I think it's too late now but like
there's part of me that's like man I
would love a game like that so it's like
open a world ish samurai game sounds
awesome
hey GameSpot how do I get a legendary
horse or camel I don't know what does I
got one what's the legendary camel do
it's golden I don't know
he says they love to play Asian but can
read Japanese same yeah so in lieu of
that game probably never getting
translated my buzz hire translator there
you go you see Viking does that'd be
kind of cool
I think Callie knows Japanese I'll just
pay her to come to my house and
translate the whole game for me no oh
god yeah be careless dudes a little
tough the guy just like got on the Oh
oh no that's okay I kind of wanted to
fall off here because
ah ha man thinking about it now yeah
actually like an assassin's created
where you're like you're like a Spartan
or something pretty cool yeah you know
that I've been replaying god of war
recently for upcoming video and I could
go it off I could go for that also this
guy's standing on fabric I don't know
why they wanted to fight me but ooh
Ryan hop says AC Vikings dad actually
been pretty cool yeah that'd be kind of
cool
oh no cutscene it said the Pharaohs had
risen or whatever oh yeah then I went
straight to the I really appreciate you
try some outfits it's making all these
cousins were really good can you give
him the beard I know that was an odd
figured out yeah and we can give him the
ponytail - yeah it was really didn't
tell you that you could do that that you
could like toggle it and where people
were really annoyed when the game came
out and like how can we have to get rid
of his hair and his yeah I mean make
sense from like a story perspective you
know you wanna like symbolize or like
the green character and change of time
but then yeah that's all I don't like
it's a very effective sure I think they
did it very effectively I like The
Witcher 3 style where it actually just
naturally grows and then you have to
like go and shave it are scarce and how
many more deal Caesar we're gonna be
released for Assassin's Creed origins
uh-huh I actually do not know yeah
that's a good question I know they were
doing a I'm sure they have it a season
passed away all games do you I mean I
can look that up I'm kind of curious now
oh so look the update they added the
little things in the corner there we go
should we not have the hair in the
bureau hair beard a note oh no towel yes
perfect cool it just what I want
I actually I kind of like the bike as a
character I didn't think I would at
first because he's like very serious but
he works I agree yeah I I definitely
found him more interesting than any of
the other reasons maybe caribou I didn't
play a lot of - I remember it but Ezio
is the favorite and it seemed like for
good reason but I've played three I
played four for was fine kennel a was
fine but I didn't love him can't wait I
mean actually was the fan favorite but I
think the problem of Kenway is he was
kind of more Emine Denis a lot of Ezio
and I was like I'm kind of over Ezio
yeah it was cool but I don't need
another Ezio although I liked how Kenway
was that's a pirate like he like
actually like did not give a [ __ ] yeah I
kind of liked that as a character
Michael is a character that's like not a
good person for most of the game and I
kind of liked it it felt true to the
sort of the pirate aspect of it but yeah
I did not like the dude and or in a
unity I remember his name oh yeah was it
I didn't like him I don't know yeah I
didn't play much I remember starting up
unity and like running into like six or
seven bugs in ten minutes and I'm like
nope right I'm not doing this game well
yeah having played it recently last year
when I did that history of Assassin's
Creed like most of the bugs are gone
which is good like that games playable
but I just remember kind of like the
story and open world like quest stuff
not being that which is a shame because
I actually really liked the setting like
Paris is just really beautiful looking
in that game yeah it was it was
something I had always wanted I remember
like ever since - I was like oh they
should do the French Revolution and then
they finally did it and it was the one I
didn't care about it was a real bummer
yeah it's this little puzzle you gotta
turn these these boys here no good wants
to know how do you guys feel uh this is
a game you keep coming back to you or
only for a DLC um no I so I'm the kind
of person who like a game like this I'll
play it I'll get my fill and then I
don't really see myself coming back to
ya the deal see what it for me has to be
like pretty like this seems pretty
interesting right but if I had nothing
to play I could see myself coming back
for this I always have something else to
play I have like a huge massive back
catalogue also unlike so like a Witcher
3 I've played a couple times but the
reason I like playing Witcher 3 is
because I like making different choices
and sort of like yeah how's how's this
gonna affect the story how what's gonna
happen if I do this the scheme doesn't
really have branching paths like no so I
I don't really feel the need to like
replay the whole thing again some wants
to know who'd win in a fight I'll tie
your @co I mean I don't know I I
finished the first Assassin's Creed II
didn't play we didn't finish the second
say I'd probably say Ezio yeah I'd say
because he's got like that handgun so he
could just shoot him you know he's got
better tech all right ok I'm just gonna
do the lowest level ones and move up I
have to do all these I assume right what
all the main ones yeah yeah just keep
you're on the right path just you're
following the main stuff and we'll
eventually get to that that good good
stuff okay so the I'm looking at the
season pass here and there's this
diverting clemens tower
perfect wouldn't be assassin's creed if
we didn't do that exact there's the
first DLC called the hidden ones that
came out in January there's the second
DLC this one which is out now and then
there's a couple item
tax and that's it actually it's not that
much is there supposed to be another one
after this - no sort of deal or is this
it from that's this is the last thing in
the season pass Oh according to Ubisoft
Ubisoft website so I don't know if there
is any more after this they haven't
announced it so as far as I'm aware this
is the last thing related to this game
yeah so far so far it kind of seems like
it like it you got a whole new area to
visit and right kind of a story that's
kind of off the deep end you know what
if you know a character I actually
forgot to mention that I liked idea
although I didn't finish this one either
I liked eat me from what was the one
before this syndicate syndicate I didn't
like Eevee I thought he was pretty good
Jacob even though he shares the same
name as me I thought was kind of dull
you just like to punch things but his
fists are like right I don't what yeah
you're an assassin you just like you
just walk into a yeah I like the dynamic
of two characters you can swap between
though like that was cool known much for
the first one here like anyone talked
about it
I don't know if it added any new any air
yeah I'm curious about new areas yeah I
mean I actually don't know I'm it's
zooming if this is the last one that's
probably the biggest one but I could be
wrong man the world in this game is so
cool though the Sun I was the first one
yeah that's the first one dang maybe so
that's actually pretty cool so I guess I
did that some stuff I was wrong and it
seems like that one is specifically
related to like the founding the
assassins Brotherhood stuff so maybe
that one's got like a little more like a
long time in the fan appeal it was like
I want to play that I don't want to swim
let's see this one seems like more
they're goofy yeah send off yeah or not
yeah yeah just like a little okay we're
gonna have more fun with it do some
weird story stuff with your mommies
we're gonna swim there yeah it's not
super far cool stab the water a little
bit to just for a good measure this game
had some good bugs too I remember a lot
of bugs it's spinning and
from what I played the game was never
buggy enough where it actually like a
fight when I rode it it crashed a couple
times but that was before the game came
in I inspected and it did crash when I
was at the preview event once but
considering how long like the long
stretches I played that for I am of the
opinion I'm lenient with bugs when
they're like goofy another dude sitting
there doesn't care
yeah especially when it's such a huge
game it's like alright as long as it's
just if it's like a goofy thing like hey
that boats spinning off in the distance
it's kind of fun it's more hey the quest
broke like that's kind of how I feel
about a I weren't trying to stealth it I
should have there's a good opportunity a
stealth opportunity in the next area
coming up Kingdom Come it's kind of one
where I feel like it maybe goes e8 too
far we're like what when two dudes are
like meshed into each other I'm bad I'm
fine with its when hey that quest broke
you can only a lot of hours of progress
someone says they're playing Assassin's
Creed 3 all watching us Wow I'm curious
why you're playing Assassin's Creed 3 in
2018 because dang ok it's 6 years old
also I feel like that game is much older
than 6 years yeah I think it might be
holy six years no I like I think it came
no wait like it came out in 2012 it is
not succeed it is 6 years old but there
have been so many Assassin's Creed games
sex that that it that kind of blows my
mind that's only six years old all right
these guys Alexander wants to know it's
just a new region yes yeah pretty pretty
good-size like I told around Pheebs
Pheebs a little bit and I moved over
here and there's still a ton and that
was one thing like even when you
completed the game I remember in the
first Assassin's Creed there was still
like a ton of the map that you hadn't
been to right the only catch was that
most the map is just desert which I a
lot of people were like there's nothing
to do and I'm like I actually kind of
like this because it just adds more to
the to the setting to the world it's
like I'm totally ok with what are you
actually gonna find in a desert sand an
oasis right you're really lucky there's
a proper way to handle scale and make it
interesting and I think this game does a
better job than most recent Ubisoft open
real games like there they seem to be
improving yeah and I think I think you
can do big areas with nothing if you do
it right I mean like the wild comes to
mind right like like not there's nothing
in there but it like I don't know it's
hard to explain if you would turn around
if you go over to the dock on your right
you talk to those guys knock knock
yeah let's talk about dude sorry they're
a couple questions here justice can take
advantage of ps4 pro capabilities
totally yeah yeah we are just playing it
yeah I played this game on a pro and it
did you know like the 4k scaling support
load times were definitely faster than
this version for plan who wants to fight
I don't know okay I'm at a calm nope
what mmm it's like an alligator no I'm
not a conflict okay okay oh oh is it
Those oh my god what all right I like
seonhwa's like or send you is attacking
them
oh my go over there
why is byuk naked what why was your bike
not naked dang it
slow me
got him set it yep look good and I'm
back all right
slight detour oh boy hi buddy Oh in the
fairy shadow hopefully not near you man
that stuns you for a while
Jim oh boy good we're good
you got it
easy swim I'm not gonna swim no
alligators prowling what what are you
Legrand says I didn't get origins
because our disappointing unity was but
the same looks really good I've always
won ancient Egypt yeah man if you got
nothing else you're interested in I
would say like if you there's nothing
else at the moment you're playing and
you can get this game probably on sale
at this point I would I would recommend
it for sure
yeah perfect
keep dealt with the crocodile I killed
him what kind of loot do we got here
alligators alright I should be able to
continue my investigation Robert Walpole
says what do you think of iron harvest
I'm not sure what that is
cool gamespot would be reviewing burnout
paradise remastered uh nope we're not
gonna give it a review or anything mean
it's basically the same game but I'm
hopefully gonna get a feature up
sometime soon I'm not too busy with
other stuff
I just wanted because I've been
replaying a lot of actually and I still
think that game is fantastic and
probably still my favorite racing game
oh that's fair that's there's a lot of
people who actually I think I like
burnout through - yeah people are either
three or they're paradise I wanted to do
a little thing about how why I think
that game is still really cool I think
three was just like cuz I never liked
racing games that much and then I played
three and I was like never mind racing
games are rad that's I'm the same way
that was me with with paradise where I'm
like I don't even care about racing game
so then I played Paris I'm like I never
mind this is actually really cool and I
for me the thing is that like there
hasn't been a game since that is
actually like done it for me but I'm
just like like I'm not into the very
like technical games like GT sport
yeah did you plan it Verizon or Verizon
that's the one I haven't played yet but
I've heard like Forza horizon 3 in
particular is apparently like the
closest it's really good yeah I didn't
play nearly as much of that as I would
have liked so I I would like to play
some of that because I hear like that's
the closest people who like burnout
paradise have like gotten to anyone cuz
yeah it's just like I don't know the GT
games are really technical than main
line for its the games are technical in
a way that's never been super
interesting to me and then Need for
Speed has just not been good for a very
long time yeah I've played quite a bit
of forts and I didn't I didn't played a
lot of horizon cuz I always kind of like
it's weird cuz I don't think I love the
technical aspect aspect but I like what
it adds when I like start to figure that
stuff out sure I like tune my car and
all that kind of stuff
oh yeah like I don't think that stuff's
bad binding and like one of the cool
things off for it says that you can I
mean you do it with pretty much any
racing game but you don't have to worry
about all that stuff you can still
enjoy it but then it's like why am I
playing this then if I'm not doing
paging it and that was kind of the cool
thing about forts of horizon is that
rather than focusing so much on
technical it focused more on a cool open
world with like stuff to do
races in it was Arkady yeah I definitely
worth it yeah I should check it out I'm
curious if we're gonna get a forts of
horizon for SWAT studios working on
fable
maybe we'll get fable horizon 5 I would
recommend taking a left go around and
kind of sneak through this is how I did
it you know very quick I'm gonna yeah do
some reconnaissance cuz you gotta find
this this is the guy one thing that I
was like I was like Ubisoft sure does
love it's like drone like things in
their games oh yeah like we don't have
our own welcome our new Far Cry primal
did that the same thing with the bird I
think it's some sort of my favorite
moments there's a super bunny hop video
where he's reviewing primal and he's
talking about how like a lot of even
though it's like caveman like the
mechanics still feel like very much like
modern equivalents and yeah he took um
the like audio from the the AC like
drone mission from Modern Warfare well
the guys like good kill good kill
yeah like put it over like the footage
of like the bird dropping like a like a
piece of poop or something alright did
some scouting game spa do I like me for
speed the run I assume you're asking we
like it is that the most recent one run
is not the most recent one I don't think
isn't the run now payback was a route
most recent one the run was the one that
was like supposed to take place across
the country but I've never played this
one whatever
I heard it was not very good but like I
said in plate so I don't know you know
one thing I was thinking about with
burnout paradise coming back
I wonder if ei is gonna be like maybe we
should stop doing Need for Speed and you
were too burnt so just a burnout thing
they had this weird thing where they had
Criterion make Mead for Speed games
yeah and then they pulled criteria now
criterion does stuff Early's part of
their team I notice stuff for like
battlefront yeah combat also that team
got really like gutted I know a lot of
people left and that teams been
downsized quite a bit so that's the
other thing is like if even if they make
a new burnout I'm just like you know the
team that was like responsible for like
burnout burnout paradise a lot of them
aren't even there anymore
so you know you kind of wonder like if
if they can even like make a new burnout
yeah not the way people would want it to
do you remember that game that yetee
eighties the long time ago by criteria
that was supposed to be like it seemed
like such a cool idea it was just like
extreme sports but by criterion so it
was like racing cars like going on hang
gliders yeah it seemed interesting like
it wasn't fleshed out all that right
that was that that press conference were
everything they showed was just like
like a tech demo basically do I need to
assassinate this guy no but you can
[ __ ] that doesn't kill them nice sunset
Far Cry 5 yeah a weird way actually Far
Cry 5 is kind of that game like where
you're just like yeah drive it heavy I
guess so
neither speed the run what did we give
it let's see here seven out of ten seven
out of ten so we read it I guess thought
it was okay that's Caroline I love how
you can tell if it's very useful so
since I heard this assassin cook is
really bad true definitely not
yeah no it's it's a fine game it's fine
game I think it's kind of a I'm not
gonna say return to form because that
was an outdated phrase but also I don't
know it's it's very different than some
of the earlier is have some screws in a
lot of ways but it feels like okay
they're starting to get their footing
back where I feel like they were kind of
stumbling for a while yeah yeah I'd
agree with that
yeah p-speed says did you like me for
speed the run uh yeah again me and J I
haven't played it oh go
but apparently we gave it a 7 so it was
ok I get my bearings here where's the
objective you gotta find it
son I did now he's a tell you it's like
not that deep in I remember finding him
pretty quick I had something marked a
while ago I thought someone says when
does this new DLC drop I don't know
exactly what time DLC drops nice oh [ __ ]
you should head down I believe he's down
I give you take a left
hey man shut up but if you're looking
for objective I believe it's to your
left
all right down down the stairs where you
kill that dude so I was asking about the
combat uh here's the full reworking but
worse than before I don't know I like it
I like it more but I guess it depends on
what you prefer it like I don't think
it's this flashy that day that's the
duty won't talk to I don't think it's as
flashy as the old ones right the old
ones were very flashy yeah I feel like
you can you didn't interact a little on
the old one right
yeah get like Joker says I stopped using
assists spotting assists in games
because I'm sick of seeing enemies
through walls yeah I kind of feel that
saying that one of the cool things I
don't know if you played much of
wildlands you could turn off all those
assists for too much yeah so like you
could still spot people but you'd have
to rely on your teammate you'd be like
like you'd have to remember like oh
there's a guy like in this room like
careful when you breach that is yeah I
didn't play that game much but if I was
I feel like that would've been the way I
would have played it was I kind of like
the idea of like turning all that stuff
off if I can do it in a game I can like
I like playing and just on it that way
where you have all these powers that'll
you see through the wall and that's fine
because that's part of the game
mechanics but I always turn off like
quest objectives and and stuff like that
because those are the kinds of games
just feel that dude yeah where this is
the kind of games where it's like really
fun to like actually like put yourself
in the world and figure stuff out yeah
yeah exactly and that was that was I
think the best way to play Ghost Recon
wildlands although that game as fun as I
had with it is definitely flawed game to
shoot sure seemed like a cool idea
though a cool cool base for Ojai like a
future a future game his story seemed
like hot garbage yeah this story was
really bad I mean
guidances hi boys
hello Pease PD says uh do you know how
old they have to be to work at any
gaming company because it's one of my
main jobs uh if you don't really like a
developer company I mean uh you know I
have a bunch of friends who work at
gaming companies you know they after
college they went and worked there I
mean it depends on what you're getting
you know a lot of those jobs like look
for you know degrees and stuff like that
so you know you got to go to college
doesn't necessary mean you have to for
that not exactly the best one it comes
to like life advice as far as that goes
but I don't know man like you know I'm
gonna say probably at least eighteen
yeah don't really know the specific your
requirements developers look for should
I try to complete this area now you
should just leave and get there next
door I think I want to kill this guy
okay that dude next to you oh there's a
guy next to me all right how's the
modern-day animus aspects so I can't
speak to a person god I'm dead oh nice I
can't speak to it personally but I've I
heard that was maybe like the weaker
aspect of the game was like the
modern-day stuff was pretty mad that's
kind of what I yeah I mean it was like I
think yeah I didn't care much for it I
don't remember it that well though I
remember there was lots of cool Easter
eggs there like you could read up on
everyone's file from the previous games
and like you could get more info on the
character you were in other characters
like like everyone's favorite boy
Desmond Miles is his name right yeah
he's still a thing they still talk about
him uh not really
okay it's like that dudes not been in
the Assassin's Creed game since three
there's just a file on them you can read
on okay okay
uh let's see Ernesto says this DLC is
huge I really like it so far
cool Brendan J Larry this is we're
playing on a base ps4 right now
but it does a pro support cyanide says
hashtag ignore me I'm sorry I don't mean
to ignore you if I did I apologize all
right it's very serious so we're on the
map now all right cool
explore a little bit more Valley of the
Kings yeah we're getting pretty close to
that that cool area I was talking about
alright and that area actually doesn't
you isn't even show up on this map so
there are the map itself there is um
actually there's more to it than just
the map that we see right now like that
afterlife area I was talking about it's
not even otherworldly yeah it's what
you're trying to say and apparently
there are multiple like the one I went
to like I was talking with the
developers and they're like oh there's a
couple of them which is actually pretty
cool humans soul gave me a compliment
he said best player of a see thank you
fantastic all of that jump was
calculated don't try it at home not
everyone gets to load back in like I do
what's up Joe how's it goin thanks for
joining Sandeep says chat one minute
late yeah that's just kind of how it
usually goes we both the chats usually
behind well like 30 seconds two minutes
especially on YouTube for whatever
reason I don't know why it's just
YouTube versus twitch twitch is always
much faster so if you want less of it
delay between chat and and us then go to
twitch over YouTube how do you guys feel
about the story without spoilers I
didn't play enough of the game to really
say much it was alright I liked it
you seem to like byuk as a character
yeah I mean it wasn't like I was in like
stuck to the TV and I had to know what's
gonna happen right it was it worked
I can't think of many Assassin's Creed
games actually where the narrative
necessarily hooked me that way like the
sometimes like Ezio is like a character
maybe grabs me but even then I don't
remember like being like so the first
one the questions have asked tooked me
like I was I wanted to figure out like
everything I'm like what's going on what
is this and then I realized they didn't
really know what's going on I just kind
of like yeah I do remember at the end
like looking up like forum post what
does it all mean like all the writing on
the wall interesting place in my opinion
so wants to see the map can do I don't
have it all filled out but as you can
see it's a pretty decent size Mass
Effect Reaper says I liked the
conspiratorial aspects of Assassin's
Creed which is why I loved one two and
four yeah that was always really cool
how do you feel about indoctrination
through Mass Effect and there's a way
easy good thing those soldiers didn't
decide to you know peek around the
corner
please leave me this one thing it is my
mother she's your parents are gone
because of this and Nefertiti will never
harm another if I can only bring it back
to my food the nor ever true my neck and
never told me where it was
he's dead Meera liked his person I don't
think that was genuine give it to me I
will return it why nothing
I wasn't magi her husband a father i
baited half of egypt with the blood of
those who took that from me
all of it over a relic like this one
okay i believe what is wrong
I was expecting something else you
promised Nefertiti's tomb lies west of
the main path in the valley I thought
you did not know where it was this is
the tomb
I've been stuck in here for ages I
figured it out okay cool
now after that tomb yeah I think there's
another way out Oh yep she said he knows
another way perfect on your turn it on
yeah there we go so this is wood yes put
AC ordinance is the best game of the
series uh I think Black Flag is still
one for me and then probably this one
yeah I
for me personally probably black flag or
breath Brotherhood was my personal
favorite when it came out yeah I heard a
lot of good things about Brotherhood and
then seemed like a lot of people were
disappointed with Revelations yeah cuz
it revelations which is like more of the
same Brotherhood felt like the like the
peak of like you know like they took
what they did with - and then like
refined it yeah you know obviously if
you go back and play now it's kind of
harder to see what made it so cool
because they're just you know they
iterate off Sanskrit so much since then
that's kind of thing about Assassin's
Creed games because they do so much and
because somebody game some sense like
evolved quest design and an open-world
and like you know climbing that like
these games don't age very well yeah I
could definitely see yeah I mean I were
at the time though I'd like sure timing
would be what drive me absolutely insane
yeah I think the one that has maybe aged
the best is actually probably four just
because I think the ship stuff still
feels pretty like novel yeah yeah you've
not played through all of them but you
played all of them recently yeah you
know like I replayed through some of
for for capture I still have my save and
just like getting back on the boat I was
like uh it's still pretty cool yeah I
like this
all right here we go okay we're gonna
get to the cool stuff all right better
be cool Jean Luc otherwise I'm
contacting Ubisoft getting my money back
injury I didn't pay for this one this is
Matt's piece fly I kept telling me balls
can be broken to create new paths but it
looks like I like playing as I know oh I
didn't I didn't I liked I thought it was
I thought it was a cool break in the
game but I wish you actually got to like
oh I didn't know I could do that also
this thing's like human wrong no Michael
graceless is digging his grave series
thank you
just put up one on far cry over the
weekend
nice
five another colors sweet and just keep
throwing on em you know there
I really liked in Far Cry 3 how the
spotting was with your camera though I
thought that was such a nice touch yeah
I wish though cuz you could take a photo
but it wouldn't actually do anything I
wish you could actually like save the
photos alright here we are
hey cool so now we are also you get this
like crazy like horse looking thing that
looks awesome
you're in this awesome like field then
yeah you're fighting all these anubis
with a new buddy I knew this looking
like cars it a new buy a new buy
probably oh yeah no there's all these
ships that are just like moving through
the like the the wheat deals the grain
whoa this is cool I'll say he seems like
a little shocked about it at first but
for the most part he's pretty like okay
cool I guess I'm here now I know maybe
he's seen enough weird stuff that he's
just like yeah some of the stuff you see
is pretty weird so this guy's clapping
behind me move
nice alright that guy just spawned again
not dealing with this right now
hey man this is actually pretty good
tons of question marks oh yeah there's
like a lot of quests there's a bunch of
side stuff is this gonna be part of the
same map so no I believe if you pull up
the map it's like a different thing it's
not related yeah see and then there's
that there's the Deeb's map so this is
this map is separate of you after and
there are multiple of these types of
areas throughout this DLC apparently so
pretty pretty cool
kill a captain kill the commander loot
the treasure man I'd love to see
something Xbox one exit but it looks
anything it look pretty good that's what
I played without that preview event you
know like good it's not blown out either
yeah that something about the saturation
on this feels weird
it cost me this TV maybe like when I
when I played I'm sure they had like HDR
turned on and all that stuff right and
they made you captain 4k oh yeah they
did they loved that 4k capture something
was stolen from the photo I would return
it so you got to do these like three
sort of like side objectives and then
you can have like a boss fight with
Nefertiti or fifty deal okay I must try
so that might be a good a good way to
end it me dying to Nefertiti exactly all
right
so this is one of them that I need to do
yeah all three quest givers are in this
like area so you can talk to all them
that somebody says why council eyes I
mean what console ps4 regular ps4
guys we get new abilities in the DLC but
I couldn't tell it's been a while but
yeah I don't think so I would set it
right then purify this sacrifice that
which would feed the gods on this sacred
ship oh so this is like a fake afterlife
I don't know yeah cause it's like he's
just kind of there I'm like is this
supposed to be the actual afterlife it's
a lie or something like that illusion
yeah I'm not really clear on that you
see I assume you kind of learn about
that of course the DLC all right cool
all right straight it ain't allowed yeah
you should go fight one of those giant
scorpions are there giant scorpions
right over there turn to your right
enjoy a little hell yeah
46 easy I've got some sweet scorpion liu
though i can bring up the abilities if
you notice any new ones doesn't look
like it though because i'm pretty sure
these were in yeah i'm not familiar
enough tree to really know someone says
why the towel why not in the afterlife
might as well dress like it i guess
someone say black ops for hype no not
from me I really liked the first black
ops I thought she was okay I actually
did not like three at least I didn't
really look like the single-player so
I'm kind of whatever on black ops for
there like shoot those guys just died in
front of us but we didn't see who did it
right
[Music]
uh assassin Saiyan hunter 18 great name
says I wish this was a new IP rather
than making new Assassin's Creed game I
think you said it in 3 or 4 min Allahu
settings with an open to roll action RPG
where magic imbues 4 in sanskrit setting
what they're doing right now seems
really far-fetched hmm I kind of see
what you're saying
I don't know this doesn't feel that
far-fetched for Assassin's Creed cuz
they've done weird stuff like that
especially with the DLCs they kind of
get a little bit weirder yeah but that
does sound like a cool idea yeah that's
a cool game I mean like mythological
open-world action RPG with magic
although let me make an MMO that was
kind of that once it was like an MMO
that was sort of lightly like every like
mythology was real or something oh you
know what I think I figured I hope I'm
getting that right all right I hear like
combat music but I'm oh it's it's a
bunch of there's a bunch of snakes on
the ground you kill them they're kind of
around the jugs you need to destroy oh I
need to destroy the jugs
why
I kind of find that I knowing that
there's no way to tell which are the I
know it's like alright I'm destroying
jugs but I'm saving the biggest one also
it's like really just like hard to see
in this area kind of didn't help no it's
just kept this like like sort of like
filter over it I think there's some to
your left
yeah there we go sweet alright next
quest someone says why did you be soft
not bring back to Sanskrit to the old
gens where it first started I'm so mad I
don't have any new Jen's just ps3 and
xbox sorry dude I mean eventually that's
just gonna happen right we're like you
know you've doing new games you're
pushing the tech forward and those old
systems don't support it like they I
don't think they could put this game on
last gen like it just wouldn't ya
wouldn't run they're doing too much with
the tech like eventually you know you
have to leave those old systems behind
so you can do new stuff with them push
the boundaries exactly
does suck though to get stuck behind
yeah that's not fun I have a friend who
plays a ton of Super Smash Bros like
that's what we always do whenever I'm
back and I saw him about the new and
he's like oh they come into Wii U and
I'm like oh no it's Oh [ __ ] only oh
sorry dude you're never gonna get a wiiu
game again sorry to say that of course
you can even buy the Wii U I gave him my
old Louise okay I don't feel that bad
you can give him your old switch a
couple years and there you go I don't
know if I'd ever get rid of my switch
yeah at this point like something about
it is like it's pretty much got all the
Wii U games that right one two so man
I'm I was thinking about it I mean we're
so early in the switches life cycle
obviously like you know it's gonna be
around for a while but I was just
thinking like man I feel like they can't
ever go back to not being portable I
know right right like whatever whatever
the new Nintendo console is like I know
the antennas always want to like push
innovation and try new things but I'm
also like that portability is pretty
awesome you should maybe just keep doing
that yeah
I check it leap off my horse Ando like I
mean I kind of go back and forth but
yeah you can get on that okay covered in
blood I wouldn't be surprised if
eventually Microsoft and Sony tried to
do a thing with if you pull your torch
you can you can drop it throw this throw
it yeah yeah
I wouldn't be surprised if they
eventually tried to do that you know
yeah but also I don't know they're kind
of going the opposite direction where
they're like trying to push like 4k and
all that stuff forward like they're not
gonna go back on that so yeah I don't
know man you feel like maybe eventually
technology will hit a point where it's
like well you know we're not gonna be
pushing resolution forward anymore
because there's no need to like once
they get past 4k it's like to even
notice a difference anymore
probably not I bet people still try to
push it though they'll still try the
consumer will be like all right what are
we doing here yeah you'll hit a point of
no return and then you'll hit a I mean
it's like whatever you'll you'll always
probably find new things to push
visually but you also hit a point where
like that won't be as much of a thing
anymore I feel like like constantly
pushing graphics and then you'll hit a
point where it's like okay what's the
new thing it's alright now we're gonna
try and get the technology of like a 1x
in like portable right like that'll be
the eventual future for us all heading
come I got some bright yeah
is the last one the third of the three
trials the final one cool and then we
can fight Nefertiti
someone's asking about graphics cards
they got a 970 and one should I upgrade
seems like the price is pretty employed
right yeah that's the thing is is I
would recommend getting a new GPU but
that's kind of tough right now wants to
fight me coward in fact I believe we're
going to be shooting a video later today
that was kind of talking about that very
subject yeah about like cryptocurrency
and sort of a state of graphics cards so
look forward to that later in the week
do it kill him dang that was a cool
animation
all right splash some water on my face
things pretty cool mm-hmm
I like this I'm really curious if those
other areas we were talking about look
quite different at all yeah because this
is pretty neat looking
jedd a hero says hey guys I'm from
Pakistan cool thanks for joining no
respect riding my horse in yeah get on
the throne does the ps4 Pro make a real
difference in Tammy pecan bread to the
normal one it definitely makes a
difference as far as like loading times
stuff like that some of the textures
look a little bit crisper I least I feel
they do but we don't really have like a
full like tech breakdown or anything
like that I've been really messed
anything
oh hey Jake I hope so
that's a pretty cool design
yeah
it cut to him surely it's a good thing I
have a funny protection that one guy
Kumar asks what's thanks for Tomb Raider
series any guesses and I want to need to
know really there I'm Derrick said
they're gonna mess one this year really
yeah I remember at the end of last year
I believe those anyway in the last year
they were like hey guys we got a new
we're gonna have like a an event coming
forward this year that's gonna like talk
about the new tune later so I don't know
if it's coming out this year but they
said they are going to reveal it this
year for sure the way they made it sound
though was that it was like it was gonna
be like an event specifically for it so
I don't know if that kind of sounded
like it was gonna be separate from e3 so
that we might hear something about the
43 I remember the rumors everyone's like
shadows of Tomb Raider like that's a
cool name that is actually pretty cool
and they should remake angel of darkness
that's a joke Angela TARDIS is really
bad although I have a friend who defense
it as their favorite tomb Raider's so I
got wrecked
I hardly put any damage on that you want
to give another track I'll give it
another shot
yeah shadowed the Tomb Raider sounds
cool
I'm wonder if it'll be like the last one
where it's gonna have a like xbox
exclusivity again whatever flake them
yeah Microsoft again about it that stuff
is always weird I don't think it will
kind of seems like --spill --spill
Spencer Spencer it seems like he doesn't
like that kind of stuff right but at the
same time it's like they don't even have
a lot yeah yeah I'm stuck for that -
yeah I'm not winning this I always
wonder because I genuinely believe Phil
Spencer when he says all that stuff yeah
but I also have to wonder like you know
if all the people around him at
Microsoft are like hey that's cool and
all but also we're a business and like
we need these things to you know like
make our like console viable you know
and at a certain point you know you can
kind of be overruled a little bit on
that stuff so you know I do definitely I
was like clout but you know there's
there's other people who also make
decisions that Microsoft dang so it says
- mater - remake I'd be cool I really
like that - murder-one remake they did
arrow string awesome yeah you're maybe a
little underpowered for this fight
[Music]
it's like I can't even like stagger um
no my gosh well there you go make sure
your definitely appropriate level when
you're doing this even with uh we did
the thing where you can kind of like
inflate your level for the dlc and even
that it seems like you still need to
yeah maybe grind out some levels or get
some gear to do it yeah do you want to
call here I think so all right cool yeah
thank you for joining us everybody with
the Assassin's Creed this seems pretty
cool actually like I like to open the
weird afterlife stuff seems pretty neat
yeah this stuff was rad good design
seems like a good way to maybe you send
off the series if or this game if this
is in fact the last yeah DLC I don't
know if they've officially confirmed it
but it's lasting for the season pass at
least so they're not gonna add anything
new with that but yeah thanks for
joining us we stream every weekday at 11
I believe it is the devil may cry HD
collection is tomorrow and yeah I look
forward to that look forward to more
stuff from us coming up you have
anything cool you're working on you want
a pimp uh I mean I don't know if I can I
think I can you know Cooney related
stuff and you know Cooney too for those
who all did yeah I want to say too much
just in case I can't say that much
Claire Fair and I know we got some
really cool stuff coming up this weekend
I mentioned that we had a video coming
up about that graphics card stuff but
also I know I don't want to say because
I don't think we've officially announced
but we have like some cool stuff coming
up like this weekend on Friday I Friday
we have something really cool that I'm
really excited about because I think
it's really good so look forward to that
and see you guys next time